[Applause]
thank you so much
great to see more people more people and
i i
missed your partial faces
we've been off for a month have you been
okay i was hoping that when we came back
here we'd be done talking about the
pandemic but
of course now the delta variant has
everyone crazy i am not worried i live
in california
the coronavirus in the air is killed by
the smoke from the fires
so i uh
but the cdc put out new mask guidelines
now which is you know it's all just so
[ __ ] confusing
indoors outdoors vaccinated vaccinated
mask not masked
the walmart shoppers don't know who to
punch anymore
so
now we're back to wearing the mask from
the front of the restaurant
until the waiter brings the breadsticks
it's called science people
sometimes sometimes i think we have to
cover our faces so other people can
cover their ass
and by the way
and by the way wash the mask i see
people with very
filthy masks out there i don't wanna i
don't wanna get the delta variant
your mask grew the delta variant
so let's see
i've been putting something off that i
should have done
two years ago or so announcing
i'm getting married no i'm kidding it's
a [ __ ] joke
[Applause]
it's a comedy show but let's not be
ridiculous
no it's it's something far worse i have
to wear glasses
i uh
cheering like it just came out as gay
what the [ __ ] so brave bill to wear gla
it's not brave i've had three lasik
surgeries i can't [ __ ] see any more
i'm at the end of my road and so um
yes i'm gonna have to
[Applause]
you had 28 years of me like this and
this is the next 28 years
sorry and okay but it has to be done
life goes on and these are progressive
lenses uh very
all i see now is white privilege
all right anyway anyway back to the
masks
yeah oh yes the house the house of
representatives they reinstated the uh
mask uh thing and uh kevin mccarthy he's
the leader of the republicans he does
not want to wear a mask
and nancy pelosi called him a [ __ ]
and then
then she remembered wait this is
congress we have a certain decorum
she said my esteemed [ __ ]
you